guys exciting new announcement this
video
is sponsored by g fuel with a new flavor
called click bait ah
what is the flavor no one knows it's
undisclosed
let me try it
that's pretty good rainbow it's rainbow
flavor did i get that right g fuel i
i cannot state enough how much i love g
fuel i drink it every day that sounds
like something they tell you to say but
i
actually do compared to other energy
drinks it actually makes you feel good i
don't know about you but whenever i
drink an energy drinks i just go
afterwards not with this baby a lot of
people used to say that
g fuel oh g let's just pre-workout as
someone who's now tried pre-workout
nah that's a fly look at my forehead
i break out like a goddamn psychopath
from these
pre-workout that i tried not g-fuel
never done me dirty like this
it's economical it's better and i highly
highly recommend you feel if you haven't
checked it out
right now there's a 30 percent up sight
wine so
try out clickbait try out the best
flavor which of course is the pewdiepie
flavor
everyone says it it's pretty well
established at this point it's yummy
yummy in your tummy check it out
link in the description you know what to
do or to run 30
off why not suck up jacksepticeye the
first host
of lawyer welcome thank you silly parker
jacksepticeye i jacksepticeye you're not
the first host
wait who else holds them apparently
marzia and i completely forgot
i'm taking people's word for it that
she's done so she lives in your house it
doesn't count
leave your memes on the reddit 19 year
[Music]
so last week of the y i actually asked
you guys something last week i did ask
you guys
that's the point of the show uh to post
jacksepticeye and pewdiepie related
memes so here we go this should be the
best names you've ever seen jack are you
ready
yes but your screen is blank on my end
for some reason
okay we're not ready hold on all right
with
40 000 up votes got ya huge giving
forehead kiss
people who put their forehead on their
screen me who put my bullets on this
this is not a jacksepticeye i mean and
don't put your balls on the screen
i thought ainsley memes were dead this
is great oh [ __ ]
everyone you just had him behind you all
the time him danny did you know
that was strange the dark ages we don't
talk about
it was the cursed arc of the anime i
think we burnt aimlessly with the
flamethrower if i remember correctly
that that that's accurate they're tracks
oh i've seen this one
oh you've seen those yeah i saw this was
everywhere
japan is cool every bit oh no
who is that i have no idea i don't know
oh yeah i remember
[Laughter]
oh that's good that's good i think that
these four panels capture it better than
the actual clip did too
oh yeah yeah this is just laughing yes
[Music]
i'm glad we can all laugh at that now oh
great
[Laughter]
how long ago was that three years four
years i think it was like three years
now i think it was the start of 2017.
what what a time man
that was different times yeah 2019 just
buy a nokia no one cares 20 20 you
should buy
[ __ ] it no one gives you changes did you
reacted the same thing three times
and said the same thing three times
no look you're consistent i appreciate
that
some people say i just rehash my content
and i don't really understand where
that's coming from
look nobody knows what it's like to
sit here and look at the same stuff over
and over and over again you just forget
the amount of videos i've reacted to and
then go back and react to them again and
everyone complains i'm like i can't
remember what i did
so many times it's in the back of my
mind i'm like have i seen this before
yeah am i gonna recall that okay i i
wonder if i've seen it off
video or if i've actually reacted to
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's it that's
it okay i saw this twice and i did a
mistake twice but the third time was a
meme
it was clearly a meme but they don't get
it because they're nine and stupid
so if it's fool you want shame on you
now they're the fools but just buy
nokia no one cares jesus christ it's
ambulation
kind of looks like it kind of looks like
really early yeah she can afford a
knockout
what's the problem yeah we'll just say
she took the same picture of three years
in a row as well
like those interviews why does she keep
posting it i don't
get it just buy one billy
you could play snake on it oh that was
dope
there was always that one person that
was so good at it and i'm like what the
[ __ ]
do you do nothing else but play snake
all day i actually i think oh i realize
now there's
there's underlying anger here for me
because i was never allowed to have the
nokia that everyone had
oh what did you have the sony ericsson
ew
yeah because that's a swedish brand and
no one in sweden wants to buy from
nokia ew yeah my mom my mom worked for
sony ericsson so i had to get a sony
accent wow i get it that's why you're on
android now instead of
iphone you're just rebelling against it
all right it happened are they past you
poco i can't believe you've done this
why would they do that
why didn't they tell all their
subscribers to stop this is perfect that
you're here because i'm not allowed to
talk about this so jack just say what
you think about this
coco melon wait t-series are
at 180 million yeah i really
never stood a chance let's get real here
jesus christ me after he reviews my meme
and i receive
a fwp badge that i also created for him
friday sweet pewdiepie oh friday's a
pewdiepie got it
me after pewdiepie downvotes my meme
with the downvote icon
full scenario baby jack i'm going to
leave you in charge for big people or
small pp on this one
uh you spell receive wrong small pp
that's my boy right there
name is jacksepticeye and i just gotta
mention your pewdiepie video
holy [ __ ] when it when what says
two thousand uh
[Music]
it must have been yeah i think so long
time not all
dvds we have there all right it's cool
yeah and that was that above that was a
mask that my korean girlfriend at the
time
made you like stuck foam on it to make
it all cool
yeah that's cool i missed a worldwide i
like the blanket background as well
yeah what you don't see is that there's
a mattress behind it
oh yeah i saw your setup video that that
was funny
hey you work with what you got yeah you
recorded in a sink
so ah that's wholesome look at this i
like that
huge pp look at us at our wedding we
broke it damn
that was our wedding we tore it
[Laughter]
let's let's
you would think it is like
you look like my dad like giving me away
for graduation or something
thanks daddy thanks for paying for my
college day
it's my wedding and you're just like
dancing with me i'm surprised my boy
finally my boy's going out of here oh my
god
oh yeah i asked i asked for a one 3d
printer you can actually slice them
someone did
that's pretty sick that's cool
oh and it slides in oh
there's there is a problem with this
where you clearly wouldn't slide slice
horizontally upwards right yeah you're
you're right-handed so you would go
the other way you tried austin
small p i'm just joking all that effort
and you still
failed how does it feel showering
it's you you're norris hey
i made it they did it that we're not i'm
clicked unless you told me i'm so glad
you're here jack thank you
[Laughter]
you just did that meme i forgot
see this is what happens this is why he
reacts at the same thing three years in
a row just buy a nokia
[Applause]
what about this that's dope that's
actually sick
love that huge peepee yeah good shading
i like that a lot kind of cringe that
it's felix and not me but i'll let it
slide
the collab people think we want
pewdiepie jacksepticeye wait wait wait
i knew it i knew it you spelled my
[ __ ] name
it's not laughlin no okay it's l
m c l o u g
h l i n okay we can still be friends
okay well nice what we see versus what
edgar sees
hmm hey that's what i see every time we
hang out this is how felix is in person
by the way the bottom one whenever he
sees you he's like oh long time no c and
then gives you a big smooch isn't it
weird when people have like
these customs for and swedish people
don't do this by the way for
for the record when people have these
country
things and they appropriate into
everyone else like i don't want to do
that yeah
i wonder if after covet now like french
people won't kiss each other on the
cheek anymore i wonder if they were like
yeah that was weird we were just
spreading that's how i thought about it
before so i don't know
do italians do it yeah italians do it oh
my god the first
time i met marcia's friends was a
nightmare dude there was 11 girls in one
room okay
it's a miracle our relationship lasted
but yeah
the collab they're doing oh they it said
guarantee me
i wonder if they would get along i
wanted that too i feel like they would
i think bibi would be very scared of him
for a while well edgar's really scared
of
everything so that was perfect
yeah when you meet that one clingy
friend after a long time
why did you make that face i i i there
was a thumb
thumbnail moment you know got it when i
created
something this [ __ ] haircut
like what the actual [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ]
me so bad he was like hey i'm gonna give
you something new
i'm like uh okay sure and this is what
this [ __ ] did to me
dude look what you're standing next to
not danny the other side
i have green i think you're fine
thank you jack kids please take this
time to show jack you
i've seen it i got a personalized tour
over discord one day
we we sat down to watch a movie and then
felix just went to
minecraft we're like just show us what
you're doing because you're playing it
anyway and we all got the personalized
tour and it was amazing
oh it was thank you stop you from
thinking i'm cool right
what no way it's my voice my brother
my brother says i'm a loser because it's
not yours
and that'll never make it as a youtuber
he's probably right i should just listen
to him
actually that's not true you know
what because i'm also saying
i'm all sort of [ __ ] that can't be
possible
actually a lot of the best youtubers are
just think of being as a superpower
wow i really like that
so do i think i can make it as a
youtuber i don't think you can
way burrito glasses coming in
did you do the food you actually did it
holy [ __ ] huge peepee burrito glasses
shout out massive big guy god
is so weird i'm also she
i'm most that's the gaelic way of
singing right
yeah you're welcome everybody i
encourage them to do youtube
jack it's been an honor and a privilege
to have you here on the y
thank you i'm glad i got to see like
four memes of me
[Laughter]
guys subscribe to jacksepticeye's
channel
oh i could surpass coco melon come on
guys let's
do it i can't i can't do it so jackie
you're gonna have to do it
guys subscribe to jack so you can i
don't want it i don't want it i just
want to sit back and chill
play video games and react to dumb hell
yeah
i don't want to have an army behind me
it's too much pressure that well
you don't get to choose okay
jack i passed on the story thank you
there you go you're grabbing it i i am
yeah
guys just also wanted to give a shout
out again to check out the link
description 30
up for for site yg fuel enter the code
pewdiepie
stuck up take advantage of this sale and
check out clickbait the new flavor what
is the flavor you tell me